I guess it was the biggest electoral  college win since Ronald Reagan said  today that you had the biggest electoral  margin since Ronald Reagan with 300 more  306 electoral votes in fact President  Obama got 365 well I'm talking about  Republican President Obama 338 when  George HW Bush 426 when he won as  president so why should Americans trust  well no I was told I was given that  information I don't I was just given we  had a very very big margin I guess I  questioned why should Americans trust  you when you accused the information  they receive of being paid when you're  providing information well I don't know  I was given that information mr. Pooh's  good actually I've seen that information  around but it was a very substantial  victory do you agree with that you're  the president